New York City is one of the most magical places to be during the holidays.
The Rockefeller Center Christmas tree and ice skating rink...
...are two of the most iconic places to see during this time.
Just don't forget to turn around...
...or you'll miss one of my favorite holiday traditions:...
...the Saks Fifth Avenue light show.
Continue along Fifth Avenue for some of the best shopping in the world...
...and take a look at the incredible window displays.
Since Macy's started the Christmas window tradition in the early 1870s,...
...New York City's biggest department stores have unveiled...
...bigger and better window displays every year.
While shopping on Fifth Avenue is great,...
...I prefer to shop at one of the holiday fairs.
Union Square is my favorite.
There's always new treasures to discover...
...from the hundreds of local and national vendors.
Walking through the market always gets me in the Christmas spirit,...
...plus I get to drink hot chocolate and eat crepes while shopping.